bund und länder beschließen neue corona
maßnahmen wieder mal wir werden
bundesweit einen zugang zu einrichtungen
und veranstaltungen der kultur und
freizeitgestaltung
unabhängig von der instanz nur für die
ängste und gelesene ermöglichen die 2g
regeln werden auch auf den einzelhandel
ausgeweitet spätestens ab einer inzidenz
von mehr als 350 neue infektionen werden
clubs und diskotheken in innenräumen
geschlossen es geht um eine große
nationale anstrengung und es geht um
solidarität
das bundesverfassungsgericht hatte am
dienstag die bundes notbremse aus dem
frühjahr für rechtens erklärt eine
bruchlandung für die fdp die sich heute
nur noch darüber freuen kann dass es
keine neuen lok da und gibt christian
lindner sagt es ist gut dass ein
neuerlicher lockdown heute nicht in
erwägung gezogen wurde
[Musik]
fangen wir mit der politischen
auswertung bei an bei uns ist eva
quadbeck journalistin leiterin des
hauptstadtbüros redaktions netzwerk
deutschland wer sind aus ihrer sicht
fragt grab bag heute die politischen
sieger und die verlierer
also es ist gut dass jetzt überhaupt mal
angepackt worden ist und wir beschlüsse
vorliegen haben mit denen es zumindest
die chance gibt eine die welle zu
brechen die ampel hat sich in den sattel
gesetzt nachdem sie vier bis sechs
wochen wirklich gezögert hat und das
notwendige einfach einfach nicht aus der
hof gekommen ist das notwendige zu tun
und die ministerpräsidenten haben das
was sie eben über wochen eingefordert
haben dass sie mehr maßnahmen brauchen
um eben in ihren ländern vor ort auch
tatsächlich lockdown maßnahmen umsetzen
zu können das haben sie bekommen also
das heißt es hat tatsächlich ein
zusammengehen bekommen gegeben nachdem
man über wochen sich parteipolitisch
darüber auseinander gesetzt hat was nun
getan werden muss und niemand hat
wirklich was getan und die schuld trifft
tatsächlich alle auf der einen seite die
länder die ja bisher die pandemische
notlage noch hätten anwenden können also
die regelungen die es dort gibt und das
einfach auch nicht in ausreichendem maß
getan haben die geschäftsführende
regierung die sich nicht mehr richtig
verantwortlich gefühlt hat selbst den
stein losgetreten hatte dass die
pandemische notlage ausgesetzt werden
soll es war gesundheitsminister jens
spahn und dann die ampel koalitionäre
die so vor ihrem geistigen auge den
freedom day da stehen sahen und
überhaupt nicht gemerkt haben was für
eine katastrophe sie reingeschlittert
sind indem sie einfach dieses in die
höhe schießen der infektionszahlen nicht
beachtet haben wie unangenehm ist es wie
peinlich ist es vielleicht auch dass
jetzt dieses infektionsschutzgesetz wenn
man es genau nimmt zum dritten mal
nachgebessert werden dass das ist jetzt
gesichtswahrende notlösung im grunde
genommen ist es die verlängerung der
pandemischen notlage mit anderen
stilistischen oder juristischen mitteln
nämlich mit dem infektionsschutzgesetz
indem wir so ziemlich das drinsteht was
die pandemische notlage für die länder
auch herr die problematische lage genau
das dürfte eben nur nicht so heißen und
es sollte auch nicht bundes not bringen
sie mehr heißen aber im grunde etwas
ähnliches und jedes wirken und jetzt
auch wenn man den politikern hinter den
kulissen vorher zugehört hat im grunde
genommen sie alle zur vernunft gekommen
haben gesagt wir lassen jetzt mal diesen
kleinkrieg das haben sie dann auch
gesagt ich bin zwar mit dem und dem
nicht so einverstanden aber ich lasse es
jetzt einfach und man hat richtig
gemerkt das hat tatsächlich heute ein
zusammenrücken gegeben zu spät aber
immerhin ist es da und ich habe immer
den eindruck uns muss es erst mal so
richtig schlecht gehen das war ja auch
im vergangenen winter so bevor man dann
in der lage ist das zu tun was auf der
hand liegt die und auch schon länger auf
der hand liegt wäre karl lauterbach ist
bei uns gesundheitsexperte
logischerweise von der spd epidemiologe
und gesundheitsminister der herzen
danach frage ich sie noch heraus
was das wert reichen diese beschlüsse
jetzt die da gefasst worden hatte ja die
beschlüsse also sind diesmal nicht ad
hoc gefasst worden also man hat sich
nicht hingesetzt hat ich sage was
überlegen wer jetzt nach sondern wir
hatten uns ja überlegt wir werden aus
also was er beim letzten mal beschlossen
haben wirkt das oder nicht und dann kam
dann raus das wird nicht das wird nicht
genug man sieht an der wirkung aber
nicht ausreichend und am wochenende
haben sich dann ein paar also
sehr renommierte modellierer und modelle
logan zusammengeschaltet so
der ob man beispielsweise michael
herrmann wie oder prise mal ein paar
andere wir haben uns dann überlegt also
welche maßnahmen würden jetzt also die
welle bremsen ohne dass wir in einem
kompletten locker angehen müssten da gab
es aber dann an ziemliche
übereinstimmungen welche maßnahmen und
wichtig sind beispielsweise masken in
schulen diese regelung dass wir die
diskussion die diskotheken clubs und
bars also schließen aber einer instituts
was wird zweig praktiziert man konnte
das konnte quasi aus den modellen heraus
geleitet werden was also wirken würde
und darüber also gut dann mit olaf
scholz gesprochen also diese gespräche
hatte ich selbst noch geführt so dass er
sich dass er im instrumentenkasten band
quasi hat was wirken würde weil man muss
er dann wenn man eine so eine
verhandlung geht muss man dem den
partner noch spielräume lassen nicht
jeder partner ist mit jeder lösung also
einverstanden aber hier war es schon
also im vergleich zu anderen also sagen
regelungen die in erinnerung war das
schon gut dass die wissenschaft an den
normen es hatte aber tatsächlich wurde
erst mal wissenschaftlich ungefähr
überlegt was brauchen wir dann wurden
dadurch daraus wurden dann instrumente
abgeleitet und diese instrumente haben
sie an olaf scholz weitergegeben es sind
die bekannten modellierer und forscher
eine prise man erinnere ich nur hat
irgendwie vor kurzem noch einen eine
rechtliche grundlage für diesen
sogenannten not schutzschalter gefordert
die intensivmediziner sagen ob diese
maßnahmen reichen nicht die leopoldina
hat im grunde genommen etwas anderes
gefordert er kriegt man sagen sie mit
einer besonderen situation in sachsen
ausgestattet sachsen hat grausame zahlen
dazu kommen wir noch dass ihnen diese
maßnahmen jetzt reichen welche erwarten
sie besonders oder denken sie das ist
tatsächlich erstmal mindeststandards wie
die kanzlerin sagte die situation in
deutschland ist sehr unterschiedlich und
ich stimme ihm absolut zu dass klein
klein dieses gegeneinander musste jetzt
dringend aufhören wir haben eine
pandemische notlage dieses land ist in
einer großen gefahr und da geht es nicht
darum wer jetzt politisch profitiert
oder wer recht bekommt oder wer einen
politischen kampf gewinnt sondern es
geht darum das richtige zu tun anhand
von fakten was ist medizinisch das ist
apple ökologisch geboten und das
passiert jetzt wir haben uns verständigt
dass ist vor allen dingen für die länder
wichtig die jetzt noch weit vor der lage
sind schleswig-holstein
nordrhein-westfalen rheinland-pfalz die
noch sehr niedrige zahlen haben und
jetzt einschwenken auf eine gemeinsame
linie die sich erklärt haben zu 2g und
vielleicht im grunde aber ein lockdown
für die ungeimpften heißt sie müssen in
sachsen jetzt die restaurants sowieso
allein 150 das ist sowieso alles schon
zu aber verheißt auf vorrat
schutzmechanismen einzuführen die
bevölkerung auch mitzunehmen 2g
einzuführen das ist wirklich auch sind
harte einschnitte auch dann für den
handel aber das ist notwendig um eben
vor der lage zu bleiben für den
freistaat sachsen ändert sich an den
dingen nichts wir liegen überall über
den maßnahmen ist schutzniveau muss viel
höher sein wir müssen eher darauf setzen
dass wir wenn wir in der kommenden woche
jetzt nicht eine deutliche beruhigung
sehen weiter nach arbeiten das dann auch
in anderen bereichen hotspots
beispielsweise die gastronomie
geschlossen werden kann und dafür muss
kommenden tagen die rechtliche
voraussetzungen geschaffen werden sie
müssen das kontrollieren vor ort ja das
ist eine selbstverständlichkeit dass es
kontrolliert werden muss aber jetzt eins
nach dem anderen machen wir haben heute
einen konsens erzielt über die
bundesländergrenzen hinweg das ist
wichtig das ist das was deutschland auch
stark gemacht hat in den ersten zwölf
monaten zumindest dieser pandemie auch
dass wir immer auf die wissenschaftler
gehört haben bin ich ganz bei ihnen herr
lauterbach das war die ersten zwölf
monate das hat im märz diesen jahres
dann aufgehört hat man versucht hat
politisch zu entscheiden das ist
kolossal schief gegangen jetzt sind wir
wieder auf diesen vernünftigen weg und
das ist gut so marco buschmann ist bei
uns der erste parlamentarische
geschäftsführer der fdp und der
zukünftige justizminister dieses landes
herr buschmann hätten sie gedacht dass
sie das was jetzt gerade beschrieben ist
alles mal mit entscheiden würden und
schon so schnell also entscheiden sie
überhaupt mit sind sie dafür ist ja die
erste entschuldigung stimmen und sehr
gut mit olaf scholz ab und ja es ist ja
auch öffentlich klar auch erklärt worden
und vieles von dem was heute beschlossen
worden ist war ja in wahrheit bei der
letzten änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
schon angelegt also nehmen sie
beispielsweise die regelung für die bars
und die klubs die sind unserer
auffassung nach das steht doch in dem
beschluss drin eigentlich jetzt schon
möglich weil es einige länder gibt die
aber der meinung sind dass sie eine
ausdrückliche regelung haben wollen
geben wir ihnen die und beispielsweise
die ausweitung des personenkreises die
impfen dürfen
das haben wir schon in der zweiten
dritten lesung angekündigt dass wir das
vorbereiten wollen deshalb finde ich das
wort vom nachbessern trifft nicht
richtig sondern wir haben uns auf den
weg gegeben dass wir erstens unbedingt
einen totalen pauschalen lockdown für
das ganze land verhindern wollen weil
der eben auch mit gesundheitlichen mit
seelischen mit sozialen
tiefen schäden verbunden ist die
kinderpsychiatrie laufen gerade über das
muss man eben auch in betracht ziehen
und zweitens dass für uns
verhältnismäßigkeit wichtig ist das
heißt es muss einen unterschied machen
ob ich in schleswig-holstein 150er
inzidenz habe oder in sachsen eine 1200
der instituts- und deshalb den ländern
einen gestaffelten instrumentenkasten
zur verfügung stellen den es ja aber
eigentlich auch vorher schon gegeben hat
und den man genauso gut bis wenigstens
zum jahresende hätte verlängern können
das war der vorschlag vom ersten
bürgermeister der schönen stadt hamburg
die lage bis zum dezember beispielsweise
zu verlängern und lieber in ruhe an
diesem gesetz zu basteln aber ganz etwas
anderes hat sich ihnen das kurz erklären
warum wir das gemacht haben weil mich
ärgert so ein bisschen ein narrativ das
immer wieder benutzt wird als sei der
neue instrumentenkasten einfach ein
weniger des alten gewesen die wahrheit
ist in dem neuen instrumentenkasten den
herr lauterbach und seine fraktion meine
fraktion und die grünen auf den weg
gebracht haben auch instrumente drin
neue ist vorher nicht gar ein auch
schärfer waren er und die auch einen
beitrag dazu geleistet haben jedenfalls
die ersten hinweise lassen das vermuten
man muss immer vorsichtig sein in der
wissenschaft aber kaum eine woche
nachdem die in kraft waren haben wir
hoffentlich jetzt den peak erreicht wir
haben ein eher wert unter 1 das ist
alles immer noch nicht genug entwarnung
wäre völlig falsch aber es zeigt sich
etwas in der sie daten denn eigentlich
ist vorher nicht gibt aber sie haben und
das werden sie auch nicht übel nehmen
dass anzusprechen den weg dahin doch
etwas anders beschritten der war
ziemlich lang mal unabhängig davon dass
sie sich für den 25.11 schon auf einen
kleinen frieden gefreut hatten gab es
diese äußerungen von ihnen ende oktober
spd grüne und fdp beenden die
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite denn es droht keine
systemische überlastung des
gesundheitssystems mehr es gibt ein
absolutes ende aller maßnahmen und alle
maßnahmen enden spätestens mit dem
frühlingsbeginn am 20 märz
haben sie dann schön daneben gelegen
müssen die bürger sich jetzt bei ihnen
bedanken dass sie sich jetzt korrigiert
also erstmal glaube ich ist es klug wenn
sich die lage verändert auch die
instrumente anzupassen zweitens ist es
so in der situation als wir diese
aussagen gemeinsam damals getroffen
haben möchte ich nur daran erinnern weil
er die lage die das beispielsweise
niedergelassenen ärzten sogar davon
gesprochen haben ende oktober alle
maßnahmen fallen zu lassen das lka hatte
seine gefahrenprognose gesenkt und der
gesundheitsminister hat ja sogar fast
schon darauf gedrängt die epidemische
lage zu beenden und in münster hat jetzt
so gesagt das hat ja auch schon etliche
male zitieren ich will nur sagen also
sofern es gehört natürlich auch genauso
wie das bundesverfassungsgericht der
bundesregierung für die bundes notbremse
zugestanden hat dass sie auf dem
damaligen kenntnisstand zu handeln
durfte muss man natürlich auch die
damalige situation in betracht ziehen wo
wir diese entscheidung getroffen haben
als sich die lage geändert hat haben wir
die massnahmen angepasst das ist auch
ausfluss des verhältnismäßigkeitsprinzip
sven sich die lage ändert muss man die
instrumente an das höchst wichtig ist es
ja nicht wenn man ende september sagt
man beendet die epidemische notlage und
landet dann knapp zwei monate später
dabei dass man ein lockdown für
ungeimpfte machen muss und sagt jetzt
führen wir die in fast rein
und sagt und jetzt führen wir die
impfpflicht ein weil man leichter über
monate versprochen hatte dass es eben
keine impfpflicht geben wird also das
ist schon eine bittere bilanz finde ich
vielleicht kann ich das kurz aufklären
das eine ist man hält sich sehr an
diesem begriff fest ich habe immer klar
gemacht das ist ein altes schutzkonzept
ein altes maßnahmenpaket dass wir durch
ein anderes ersetzen dass das diesen
namen trägt und ich habe das damals in
der pressekonferenz wie auch im
parlament das werden ihre redakteure
sicherlich auch gesehen haben immer
klargestellt corona ist nicht vorbei
corona bleibt gefährlich wir brauchen
maßnahmen und wir haben sogar im ersten
maßnahmenpaket dass wir damals
vorgeschlagen haben dinge auf rechtlich
sichere grundlage gestellt die hygiene
konzepte mit personen obergrenzen waren
vor umstritten das haben wir klar
gestellt wir haben zweig auf rechtlich
sichere beine gestellt weil vorher war
es umstritten ob man
zugangsbeschränkungen an diese nachweise
knüpfen kann also so zu tun als hätten
wir damals alles auf machen wollen ist
objektiv falsch das ist der erste punkt
den ich glaube ich dass weitere das 2 es
ist natürlich jetzt ein bisschen
schwierig wenn sie sagen ihr wolltet zu
wenig machen das finde ich schlecht aber
wenn ihr dann die instrumente an passt
dann ist es auch irgendwie falsch
sondern er ich glaube das ist nicht
richtig wir müssen auf die lage schauen
und wenn sich die lage verändert und
verschlimmert dann muss man die
instrumente in die lager an und sie ist
genau das hat karlsruhe gesagt es hat im
grunde gesagt die verantwortung zu
handeln liegt bei der politik also
entscheiden first und bedenken sagt man
soll nicht darauf warten das ist
verfassungsrechtlich erstmal eine
expertise gibt um in einer solchen
situation handeln zu können ich
widerspreche in ungerne aber ich glaube
es ist ich kann das ist sehr nahe aber
dann doch knapp daneben was karlsruhe
gesagt hat ist dass der gesetzgeber in
dieser sendereihe in einer
gefahrensituation von ausserordentlicher
dramatik wenn überragend
gemeinschaftsgüter gefühl hat 7 1
wirklichkeit ausreicht um zu maßnahmen
zur einen sehr weiten
entscheidungsspielraum hat um die lage
zu beurteilen und darüber zu entscheiden
welche instrumente angemessen sind damit
hat karlsruhe im prinzip auch der ampel
den spielraum gegeben ein eigenes das
konzept auf eine möglichst bald zumachen
und das haben wir ja auch getan und ich
möchte noch mal einen hinweis geben ich
glaube noch nie war ein regierungs- und
mehrheits übergang in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik so schwierig und so
komplex dass ist ein argumente haben wir
hier schon gewogen in ihrem sinne
ehrlich gesagt würde jetzt
zu ende führen und wer hätte eigentlich
gedacht dass wir so schnell im parlament
als es auch noch gar keinen
koalitionsvertrag gab als drei
fraktionen in der lage sind so schnell
gesetze anzupassen ich finde das war
aller ihre männer hätte es bis ende des
jahres vielleicht einfach laufen lassen
und sich diesen stress nicht machen also
herr lauterbach frage ist olaf scholz
der bundeskanzler hat zu viel rücksicht
genommen auf die fdp sind wir jetzt mit
allem zu spät nein ich glaube hat gesagt
wir hätten vier wochen sechs wochen
schneller sein dürfen aus zunächst
einmal also der bundeskanzler ist ja
noch nicht mal im amt zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt und was olaf scholz gemacht
hat ich finde es wirklich also
ja
das richtige paradigmas wir haben uns
jetzt hingesetzt wir haben die
wissenschaftler zusammen gerufen wir
haben versucht die lage zu analysieren
und haben daraus dann regeln entwickelt
die auch in der ampel besprochen worden
sind und auch noch die cdu mit ins boot
geholt haben denn ab und herzlich um sie
auf die deutschen mediziner sagen herr
lauterbach seit wochen ja dass sie am
limit ziemlich jeden der die leopoldina
sagt wir müssen sogar darüber nachdenken
ich komme jetzt leopoldina nochmal ganz
großartig wollen sie sagen also ich
erwähnen dass deshalb weil ich glaube so
sollten wir es auch nach vorne machen
wir werden ja jetzt diesen aus dem
wissenschaftlichen beraterkreis haben
das hängt am bundeskanzleramt und wenn
wir uns sagen wir regelmäßig also an
also ein bild für die leute über die
lage verschaffen und dann die gesetze
anpassen oder die regeln anpassen dann
ist das aus meiner sicht wie es
passieren sollte evidenzbasierte politik
und das hatten wir eine ganze zeit lang
verlassen was hatten sie ja so geradeaus
gefühl da stimme ich ihnen zu wir haben
das eine zeit lang sehr erfolgreich
gemacht dann haben wir es verlassen
jetzt kehren wir dazu das hat olaf
scholz relativ schnell jetzt wieder
eingeführt und die seele der
spd-politiker ich höre dass raus er
wieder sagte noch vor drei wochen ganz
deutschland ist ein einziger ausbruch
damit hat er ja auch nicht unrecht und
ich habe ich ich muss dazu sagen ich
habe ja sehr früh als wissenschaftler
darauf hingewiesen dass wir also zu
wenig beschlossen das muss ja auch
gesagt werden ich habe sehr sehr früh
zum beispiel darauf hingewiesen wir
brauchen vielmehr zweig ich habe sehr
früh darauf hingewiesen dass wir robust
sein müssen und so weiter und so fort
somit das geht hier nicht darum also die
wissenschaftler haben das problem
gesehen aber man darf auch mal dass ich
zumindest und das muss man hier fair
bewirbt man kann nicht sagen hätte jetzt
schon die die also die regierung früher
übernehmen müssen bevor er im amt ist
dass das fängt ja jetzt erst an so also
natürlich versucht der bürger fair zu
bleiben am allermeisten würde ihm helfen
also einheitliche regelungen haben einen
wahrscheinlich wahnsinnig viel nachteile
aber sie haben einen eklatanten vorteil
der bürger weiß einfach voran er ist und
das wusste er in den letzten wochen
nicht und ich begrüße eine weitere gäste
in unserer sendung und über sie freuen
wir uns sehr bei uns ist die biologin
und immunologin christine falk sie ist
die präsidentin der deutschen
gesellschaft für immunologie frau halt
wichtige frage an sie und die allererste
wenn sie sich diese maßnahmen von heute
anschauen sagen sie denn das reicht aus
die intensivmediziner sind voller sorge
selbst die leopoldina hat vorgeschlagen
dass man auch über kontakt
beschränkungen für geimpfte nachdenken
müsste wenn die instanzen nicht
untergehen
guten abend
vielen dank für die einladung freue mich
sehr dass ich dabei sein darf ich denke
wir haben jetzt die rechtliche seite ein
bisschen gesehen und die politische es
geht um menschenleben wir haben über
70.000 neue infektionen an einem tag es
werden innerhalb deutschlands
intensivpatienten mit dem hubschrauber
von einem klinikum in ein nächstes
verdikt wenn das keine notsituation ist
weiß ich nicht wie man an den
notsituation beschreiben soll und wenn
wir etwas aus der pandemie gelernt haben
ist dass man schnell handeln muss und
das steht natürlich im widerspruch mit
politischen vorgängen das ist schon klar
aber nichtsdestotrotz geht es um
menschenleben und wenn wir diese zahlen
nicht in den griff bekommen dann ist
jetzt absehbar und das sagen die
intensivmediziner seit wochen dass die
intensiv kapazitäten sehr bald nicht
mehr ausreichen werden nämlich schon vor
weihnachten nicht und daher ist das was
heute beschlossen wurde dann herr
lauterbach hat es gesagt da waren ja
modellierer mit beteiligt um zu sagen
was kann man machen und wie kann man
versuchen auf der datenbasis
vorausschauen zu überlegen ob das reicht
das geht nur wenn alle mitmachen wenn
jeder und jedem einzelnen klar ist dass
es jetzt an dem handeln der einzelnen
person liegt sich an die maßnahmen zu
halten und gemeinsam zu erreichen dass
die zahlen nicht nur in den griff zu
kriegen sind die dürfen nicht so hoch
bleiben sondern wir müssen die
infektionszahlen nach untergrund nach
unten bringen damit weniger menschen in
die krankenhäuser müssen weniger
intensiv flüchtigen patienten da sind
und wir das besser in den griff bekommen
deswegen teile ich die sorge und
gleichzeitig ist der appell an die leute
wirklich mitzumachen wenn das wenn das
nicht passiert wird eng wir müssen es
anwenden und es müssen alle mitmachen
was jetzt an den berühmten
instrumentenkasten auf dem tisch liegt
herr kretschmar wir reden über sachsen
und ich frage vorher vielleicht normal
warum eigentlich diese von den
ministerpräsidenten cdu immer ins feld
geführte epidemische notlage
mit ihrem instrumentenkasten nicht
ausgereicht hat in sachsen diesen
zustand zu verhindern woran lag es denn
dann das ist wie gesagt mit der apple
dem ökologischen lage notlage wäre der
gesamte instrumentenkasten da man müsste
jetzt nicht anfangen das ist ja das
problem gewesen sie haben das video
gezeigt dass es vom 27
oktober wir haben sechs tage später
schon zweig beschlossen und die ersten
einschränkungen
wir haben ein system gehabt vorwarnstufe
überlastung stufe was auf rk ii
kriterien beruht was von den medizinern
entwickelt worden ist die haben nur in
einem punkt die sache nicht richtig
eingeschätzt dass die dynamik bei delta
um so vieles höher ist als bei der
ursprungs warnte dass es eben nicht vier
oder sechs wochen dauert bevor man von
der einen zur anderen stufe kommt
sondern eigentlich zehn oder 14 tage
und deswegen war das schnelle eingreifen
dann notwendig buß und bettag 20 uhr war
hier die entscheidung im deutschen
bundestag ich finde schon mit einer
notlösung mit so einer verlängerung von
übergangsfristen zu arbeiten aber sei es
drum und wir haben zwei tage später
schon entschieden und das in einem
umfang wie es sonst nirgendwo ist es
gibt keine fans mehr im stadion die
körpernahen dienstleistungen sind
geschlossen ist findet kein sport mehr
statt es findet keine kulturstadt die
gaststätten so zu es gibt ausgangs
beschränkung also der gesamte bereich
und die sorge war ja in dem vorfeld dass
diese maßnahmen wegfallen könnten nach
dem 24 november das ist jetzt nicht mehr
der fall nach der heutigen verständigung
gehe ich auch davon aus sie haben einmal
bestätigt
und wir müssen natürlich überlegen wenn
die zahlen bei uns nicht sinken und das
müssen sie wir müssen runter wir müssen
auf mindestens ein zehntel von den
heutigen zahlen und das braucht eine
deutliche dynamik nach unten dann muss
nachgesteuert werden wir gucken noch mal
die zahlen von sachsen an und dann ist
gleich frau quadbeck dran
die sieben tage inzidenz in sachsen
1180 höchstwert in deutschland nur etwas
mehr als 58 prozent sind vollständig
geimpft der niedrigste wert mehr als die
hälfte aller intensivstationen melden
eingeschränkten betrieb im osterzgebirge
sind 95 prozent der intensivbetten
belegt sachsen ist hochburg von corona
leugnern laut einer studie der uni wien
hält rund jeder vierte die pandemie für
eine verschwörung am wochenende
demonstrierten mehrere hundert menschen
gegen eine impfpflicht
von sachsen nämlich dass das was jetzt
notwendig wäre dass die bevölkerung
tatsächlich mit macht und sich an die
regeln hält dass das in sachsen nicht
ausreichend passiert weil es sind ja es
sachsen ist das land mit der niedrigsten
impfquote mit der höchsten infektions
quote da sage ich ihnen nichts neues und
ich kann mich nicht so gut aus in diesem
bundesland aber nach allem was ich lese
von berichten auch von kollegen
passieren da eben dinge dass massiv
gegen korona regeln verstoßen wird die
polizei rückt an man kennt sich
untereinander man zwingt sich zu die
polizei und wieder ab und das passiert
rein gar nichts und das wenn so etwas
eben gehäuft passiert dann können ihre
maßnahmen noch so gut sein dann wird das
nicht funktionieren sie werden
tatsächlich in sachsen besser
kontrollieren müssen und wahrscheinlich
auch härter vorgehen müssen gegen
querdenker rechtsradikale die zusätzlich
die leute
aufwiegeln und die natürlich auch bei
ihren demonstrationen gegen korona
maßnahmen verstoßen und in teilen
einfach auch toleriert werden während
diejenigen die sich an die regeln halten
am ende immer die betten sind ja das ist
der blick von außen und das bestimmt
auch nicht ganz falsch aber kann auch
nichts 100 prozent zutreffend seien sie
haben recht eine niedrige impfquote auf
diesem niveau wird nicht funktionieren
die zur impfung muss nach oben kommen
und man merkt jetzt in einem
gesellschaftlichen diskurs wie kirchen
wie handwerk wie kultur wie bei allen
auch bei den bürgermeistern das
bewusstsein für genau dieses problem
wächst und das ist die die erste
voraussetzung die zweite ist alle sehen
die überlastungen den krankenhäusern
sind der meinung so geht es nicht wir
brauchen hier eine gemeinsame
einen wellenbrecher sie sehen die
maßnahmen die wir ergriffen haben und
auch dass das nichts ist was jetzt bis
märz april sein kann man muss also
schnell aus der situation kommen
deswegen spüre ich auch die bereitschaft
über das jetzige maß hinaus zu gehen was
mich auch sehr erfreut sie haben was die
kontrollen angeht absolut recht es
braucht er viel mehr konsequenz deswegen
ist die polizei jetzt neben den autos
polizeibehörden die eigentlich zuständig
sind wirklich massiv dabei und die
zahlen die statistiken die ich sehe
zeigen dass er genau und ich möchte
einen punkt sagen weil der
bundesjustizminister in spe bei uns ist
und es meine ich jetzt wirklich weil es
mich umtreibt das sind diese telegramm
gruppen diese rechtsextremen gruppen von
30-40 80.000 menschen die sich
zusammengetan haben und bösartigste
propaganda das hätte aber auch wirklich
zersetzende dinge programmieren und wir
müssen da etwas tun das geht so nicht es
passt nicht mit unserem prinzip von von
meinungsfreiheit zusammen mit unserer
medienregulierung diese leute verstecken
sich dahinter dass das ein
nachrichtendienst ist und kein soziales
netzwerk ich würde mich sehr wünschen
wenn wir da möglichst schnell nach ihrer
amtsübernahme in ein vernünftiges
gespräch kommen das muss alles so
gemacht werden einfach ganz ganz wichtig
ich glaube dass andere dinge also das
muss nicht falsch seien aber andere
dinge sind natürlich dringender der bund
hat geld auch in sachsen zur verfügung
gestellt um kapazitäten auszubauen
ich würde sie dringend auffordern dieses
geld zu nehmen und den impfzentren zu
strecken schmalen der es nicht so kann
sich mit mir hier nicht reden also wenn
wir ihn kommt aus berlin und irgendwas
über geld bezahlt des bundestags schluss
wirklich er
ist minister werde und schiebe das jetzt
vorüber sein gesicht eines mannes an so
die lage in ihrem land die müssen sie
lösen
so erklären wie das gestellt dass ich
hier hin und sagen ja wir mussten schon
x-mal mann haben wir decken sie händen
die maßnahme japanische lage wie bisher
320 nur wenn wir voll ansatz von gucci
haben wirklich nicht genutzt sie haben
einen notfallordner in kraft gesetzt die
nicht mal die volle übergangsfrist
genutzt lassen sie mich nur ausreden
weil ich mich hier nicht ermögliche sich
man auf der basis das können sie nicht
nennen sie hatten alle möglichkeiten sie
haben sie nicht genutzt die lage außer
kontrolle reiche jetzt versuchen sie ist
mir unter dem bund in die schuhe
schieben so geht ich habe hier mit ihnen
eine vernünftige anständige diskussion
geführt ich habe heute eine langsam ich
habe eine ministerpräsident konferenz
erlebt und habe noch einmal deutlich
gesagt die neue bundesregierung olaf
scholz sehr ordentlich was da passiert
und sie kommen jetzt und erzählen mir
irgendwas von geld und impfen ohne zu
wissen was frauen passiert wir haben
eine
gesundheitsministerin die von früh bis
abends mit dem drk mit den kliniken
unterwegs ist und ich kann doch jetzt
hier nicht zulassen dass sie das gar
nicht wissen kann sich hinstellt und
sagt nehmen sie gefälligst das geld des
bundes und machen so gehen und das ist
nicht sehr engagiert und ich möchte sie
ausdrücklich loben aber ein ranzen hat
es so dass die
infrastruktur ausgebaut werden muss es
gibt lange schlangen es gibt ja es gibt
lieferengpässe und das müssen wir in
sachsen
gibt es auch in anderen das stimmt aber
trotzdem leicht ist es so dass das
instrumentarium dass der bund zur
verfügung gestellt hat von sachsen nicht
voll ausgeschöpft worden ist und dass
eine entscheidung vor ort die
respektiere ich aber ich lasse mir nicht
vorwerfen lassen nicht wahrsagen viel
denn natürlich etwas persönliches sagen
die
allerjüngsten also auswertungen
kontaktdaten auswertungen zu sachsen
zeigen eine sehr positive tendenz ist
tatsächlich so also ich habe heute nach
ich hatte heute nachmittag also kontakt
also mit dem oder lehrern hier vom rk ii
und man sieht insbesondere an den
wochenenden gab es immer starke zunahmen
der kontakte muss jetzt zu wirken aber
den zusammen also ich will mich in den
staaten nicht einmischen das ist nicht
der punkt aber ist also wir müssen
zusammenhalten wir kommen sonst nicht
klar wir sehen hier die wirkung der
maßnahmen und wir legen jetzt nach und
wir haben ja herrn kretschmer wir haben
ja sachsen die möglichkeit geben noch
einmal nachzulegen und wir werden auch
mehr impfstoff jetzt haus bringen somit
wenn wir zusammenhalten schaffen wir das
wir können hier dürften sich hier nicht
also in zwei neben völlig recht in sehr
für zusammenhalt aber ich finde wir
haben in der letzten runde durch bayern
war ein herr kubicki erlebt der mit
einer absoluten nase hoch uns hier
irgendwas erzählt hat und ich habe mir
eigentlich gewünscht auch weil sie eine
vernünftige art und weise wie man den
tag gelegt haben dass sie jetzt einen
anderen politikstil und jetzt vergessen
wir die sache wie sie ist ich würde
gerne mit ihnen über t ich würde gerne
nicht ich brauche und nicht die hilfe
soll das ist ein problem in booten
gehört ok und das ist sein problem was
wir als bundesrepublik deutschland haben
was diese gesellschaft dass diese
demokratie in größenordnung gefährdet
durch nehmen würde ich gerne mit ihnen
darüber reden und ich würde gerne wenn
sie eine frage haben zum impfen dann
können wir darüber sprechen die leute
vor ort kämpfen und tun und sie was sie
nicht erleben und können ist dass jemand
in der talkshow der gar nicht die
situation vor ort kennt dann eben mal
sagt nehmen sie gefälligst das geld des
bundes und machen sie das ordentlich ich
mache das sehr sehr ordentlich reden wir
kurz über ihren kollegen höchst aus
nordrhein westfalen der auch gesagt hat
der bund ist schuld an der situation in
der wir jetzt sind dramatische appelle
aus auch nordrhein-westfalen und dann
tanzen die jecken und es gibt die
fußballspiele mit den zehntausenden
wie sehr haben sie sich darüber
gewundert also wird dann nicht doch auch
immer noch ein politisches spiel
gespielt ich habe die entscheidung
getroffen dass es keine fans im stadion
gibt das hat vor über zehn tagen deshalb
mir sehr viel arbeit gemacht das hat
mich sehr viel kraft gekostet habe ich
aus tiefer überzeugung getroffen
deswegen bin ich auch nicht bereit mir
an hängen zu lassen oder meiner
koalition in sachsen dass sie nicht
entschieden handelt wir haben heute
versucht einen vorschlag zu machen den
sie auch mit vorbereitet haben der
leider nicht durchgekommen ist keine
fans mehr im stadion oder nur ganz wenig
sie haben 5000 vorgeschlagen außerdem
folge aber so ist das wenn man einigen
sich also in dem einen oder anderen
punkt also damit muss man leben ich
finde es auf jeden fall schon mal
richtig dass man auf 15.000 drunter geht
das schon mal bei mir hatte 5000 viel
besser gefahren weil das also auch
einfach schlicht ergreifend die anfahrt
die abfahrt die geselligkeit danach
somit wäre 5000 deutlich besser gewesen
aber wenn man jetzt das gesamtportfolio
der beschlüsse von heute sieht das ist
dass man sich damit kann man sich sehen
ob ich ganz nah ihn vor allen dingen
weil ja noch dass ein booster nein geld
ganz wichtige säule geworden sich mein
wann hat es schon mal eine solche ansage
gegeben bis zur 13 sollte gerade grumman
im 30 millionen und wir kriegen frau
quadbeck das ist auch interessant wir
kriegen einen general ähnlich wie die
italiener ihren gebirgsjäger haben wir
jetzt auch einen verantwortlichen
general ist das mehr als symbolik
also ich würd mal sagen neue besen
kehren gut gramms grundsätzlich halte
ich das nicht für verkehrt noch mal ein
bisschen nachzuladen wenn es darum geht
mehr infrastruktur zu schaffen um den
impfstoff wirklich auch in die oberarme
bei den leuten zu bekommen ich hatte
jetzt auch nicht so große sorge dass die
regierung das militär ismus anheimfällt
was ich aber eher ungünstig finde ist
dass immer noch nicht wissen wer der
gesundheitsminister oder die
gesundheitsministerin werden soll dann
ist das schon so ein general im
kanzleramt ich hätte gedacht wenn dann
müssten solche persönlichkeiten ja als
team antreten und nicht der eine macht
schon mal und der andere kommt dann ins
amt und muss man gucken welche rolle er
dann spielt also dann macht der general
corona und der neue gesundheitsminister
macht dann krankenhaus reform und kissen
also das wäre sicherlich keine ganz so
gute keine ganze arbeitet heilung legt
sie das erklären weil ich in der runde
saß die diese entscheidung mitgetroffen
hat
und die entscheidung für den general
breuer hat ja etwas damit zu tun dass
man sich die frage stellen muss wer sind
die besten experten um eine große zahl
an menschen eine große menge an material
in großen räumen optimal zu reduzieren
und das ist eine der großen stärken von
militär und auch vom bundeswehr zweitens
lernen offiziere viel stärker als andere
berufsgruppen auch unter unsicherheit
abgewogen aber zügig zu entscheiden also
das herz die krisenmanager und eben und
es ist eben nicht corona politik wofür
der gesundheitsminister zuständig ist
sondern es ist eine logistische
handwerkliche aufgabe den impfstoff dem
wir haben ist so optimal zu verteilen
dass er wirklich schnell in die oberarme
kriegt man jetzt gleich wieder sagen ob
er sich über diesen herrnbräu erfreut ja
weil sachsen kennt ihn sogar die sachsen
beraten und ist in ihren augen auch eine
gute entscheidung nein es war der
kommandeur der brigade freistaat sachsen
private 37 ein wunderbarer mensch der
beim hochwasser geholfen hat wer bei
vielen katastrophen dabei war der kann
viel und dieser krisenstab mit dem
general breuer hat einen zweck wenn es
tatsächlich um die logistik gibt und die
unterstützung jetzt auch bei dem
ausfliegen der patienten aber daneben
muss stehen und das ist ja jetzt im
werden die rechtlichen instrumente wir
brauchen eben wirklich diese echten
instrumente um den block haben die
tabelle zu brechen lockdown zu verfügen
da wo es sein muss regional ansonsten
sind wir blank und wir haben jetzt
mehrmals nachgesteuert jetzt kommt die
weihnachtszeit da kann man nicht dem
bundestag mal ebenso schnell wieder
zusammenbringen deswegen beide dinge
müssen zusammen wissen parallel
passieren und müssen eben auch stich
genau passieren damit nicht das einen
ausläuft und nicht mehr möglich ist und
dass neue noch nicht in gang gesetzt wir
gucken noch mal zurück um dann aber
sowas von nach vorne zu schauen herr
lauterbach es gab eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz könnte ich
eigentlich auch ein kritischer fragen im
august des jahres 21 da hat eine
besorgte kanzlerin gesagt wir brauchen
85% impfquote und wir haben überall nur
55 die reaktionen der
ministerpräsidenten war offensichtlich
begeisterung im worte im tun nichts was
lässt sie jetzt eigentlich hoffen dass
jetzt ganz viel geschieht und dass wir
sogar in fünf wochen 30 millionen
schaffen zunächst ganz einfach wir haben
die 30 millionen also wir haben diesen
stoff des tatsächlich da
und
keiner mehr was dagegen die jetzt ist
also der der ernst der lage ist jetzt
also allgemeine bevölkerung aber auch in
der politik parteiübergreifend
begriffen es ist einfach so das war im
august hat nicht so also ich habe zum
beispiel im august also dafür plädiert
dass wir die eben zentren offen lassen
da bin ich fast ausgelacht worden es war
an der grenze also
nicht mit dem echten da waren auch
welche dabei das stehen dafür plädiert
das viel eher geimpft werden soll dieses
booster impfung kommt wann war das
gewicht im juli im juli im juli war im
juli kamen die israelischen daten die
zeigten dass jeder gewusst hat werden
muss und haben sich das damals
vorgetragen habe da hohen gelästert
sonntag
nicht von der ständigen impfkommission
gab es die kritiker von der stirn gegen
die von der politik sondern der
ständigen impfkommission hat es da noch
ewig gedauert bis man da an die
empfehlung gegeben hat die über
70-jährigen sind somit die verhältnisse
waren unbequem um es war so ausdrücken
jetzt sind die verhältnisse aber andere
die bereitschaft jetzt auch
wissenschaftler zu hören eine
evidenzbasierte politik zu machen
wissenschaftsbasierte politik zu machen
schnell zu handeln den impfstoff also
dazu zu verbringen also die eben center
schnell wieder aufzubauen die
bereitschaft ist überall da von daher
bin ich viel optimistischer ich glaube
das ist ein bisschen ganz einer geistig
ein element will ich beitragen weil man
nicht einfach sagen kann die politik es
gab länder die im august bereits die
älteren menschen angeschrieben haben
schleswig holstein hat im august sofort
die menschen angeschrieben hat
angefangen zu boostern deshalb haben wir
eine hervorragende bußtag wurde man kann
nicht sagen die länder oder die
ministerpräsidenten es gab länder wie
schleswig holstein oder was gemacht
haben oder auch hamburg absolut aber
schließlich holstein überhaupt die
norddeutschen bundesländer waren da
einfach couragierter und schneller wir
besorgen her jetzt auch dafür das
rechtlich mehr menschen diese spritzen
setzen können und es ist übrigens so
gewesen dass damals auch ganz falsche
zeichen gesetzt wollen sind also sachsen
hat glaube ich sogar teilweise die
masken pflicht im juli aufgehoben was ja
auch ein signal war deshalb wundere ich
mich immer dass uns signale unterstellt
werden auch andere haben signale gesetzt
aber das ist die vergangenheit wir
schauen jetzt nach vorne
wir haben jetzt den gemeinsamen willen
diese kraftanstrengung
hinzugekommen rechtlich logistisch und
vom impfstoff hier nur daher rein
praktischen vorschlag also wir haben ja
eben erwähnt also sind 90 lieber eine
antwort überlegen ob sie jetzt unser
gesundheitsminister werden und swr
lauterbach zwischendurch fangen wir ganz
schnell nochmal frau vorfeld haben wir
nicht eigentlich längst eine völlig neue
situation weil da ist nikon wir wissen
dass der impfstoff vielleicht nur vier
monate sicher ist in bestimmten risiko
und altersgruppen wir haben tatsächlich
delta 99 prozent aber haben fälle jetzt
auch hier in deutschland und wissen über
diese neue mutation wahnsinnig wenig was
lässt sie hoffen dass wir wirklich
selbst mit 30 millionen bis weihnachten
in eine andere situation kommt also zum
einen muss man ganz dringend noch mal
erwähnen dass die impfung der
langfristige weg ist alle maßnahmen die
wir jetzt haben sind ja kurzfristig
gedacht was uns lange hilft es die
impfung warum weil wir drei ab berlin
aufbauen und das ist einmal wichtig zu
erwähnen um zu verstehen warum wir mit
omikron ein auge drauf haben müssen aber
warum es nicht so ist dass da der
impfschutz nicht mehr hilft die erste ab
der linie sind die abfangjäger das sind
die berühmten antikörper die schon hier
im nasen rachen raum sitzen wenn das
virus angeflogen kommt können die das
sofort neutralisieren die sind hoch
spezifisch und die können unter
umständen nicht mehr ganz so gut auf
mich reagieren auf delta schon noch ganz
gut die sind aber nicht alleine wir
haben die zweite antikörper linie die
quasi noch mal eine sicherheitslinie 1
darstellt weil die fresszellen damit
aktiviert werden und die sind sehr viel
deutlicher in der lage alle varianten im
moment abzudecken das wird gerade
getestet deswegen werden wir sehen wie
gut dass gegen umtrunk nikon geht und
die dritte linie sind unsere t zellen
die kommen sowieso erst in aktion wenn
die zellen schon infiziert sind und das
sind quasi mobile einsatzteams die haben
killerkommandos dabei und hilfstruppen
und die eliminieren des virus wenn es
hier im nasen drin ist und die können
sehr gut die verschiedenen varianten
immer noch eliminieren und deswegen ist
die attacke an der stelle sicher wenn
die sozusagen in der stufen linie
aufbauen und sagen der sicherste da ich
unten sind die t zellen die schicht 1
oben drüber sind die zweite antikörper
mit den fresszellen um ganz oben sind
die abfangjäger und wenn uns die
abfangjäger abhanden kommen haben wir
die anderen immer noch und die frage ist
wieviel viruslast haben wir und wie viel
abfangjäger brauchen wir jede einzelne
und als gemeinschaft im moment haben wir
eine situation wo wir für alle menschen
gleichermaßen die ideale abwehrlinie mit
sämtlichen abwehr jägern brauchen und
wenn wir die haben es mit der dritten
impfung dieses niveau erreicht wenn wir
aber weniger viruslast haben brauchen
wir nicht mehr dieses allerhöchstem
niveau das heißt die impfungen die wir
haben gerade mit drei mal impfen wird
ein langfristiges gedächtnis induzieren
die menschen haben dann eine
langfristigen schutz die frage wie
schnell er reaktiviert werden muss ist
eine frage wie viel wie russland haben
wir deswegen hängen die beiden dinge
zusammen und kann man trotzdem menschen
verstehen die sagen dass sie erst mal
mit der dritten impfung warten wollen ob
nämlich der impfstoff angepasste also
sie verstehen die frage wir impfen ja
eigentlich noch mit dem alten impfstoff
der ist auch mit delta nicht angepasst
worden ist es klug wenn menschen sagen
ich warte dann lieber bis es einen
angepassten impfstoff gibt es leider
nicht weil es zu lange dauert und die
impfstoffe die wir jetzt haben machen
eine sehr gute grundimmunisierung und
die brauchen wir jetzt und deswegen
jetzt nicht nur die dritte impfung die
ist sehr sehr wichtig wir brauchen
unbedingt stichwort sachsen hat schon
mal sie brauchen mehr erst geimpfte
menschen wir müssen unbedingt mehr
überzeugungsarbeit leisten dass es eben
keine langzeitfolgen gibt dass die
impfstoffe jahrelang jahrzehntelang
entwickelt wurden was neues ist das
virus dass wir wirklich vertrauen
schaffen dass ihr mehr erst kämpfte
haben denn wir brauchen die quote
deutlich über 85 prozent bundesweit je
mehr desto besser und deswegen ist er
ganz dringende appell nochmal die
menschen zu erreichen auf allen ebenen
dass sie sich wirklich jetzt impfen ob
wir später im nächsten jahr dann
angepasst impfstoffe haben umso besser
aber jetzt sind die schon sehr gut die
heilung dauert ungefähr sechs monate
herr lauterbach überlegt sich immer noch
über unsere gesundheitsminister wird
unser der der herzen andrea nahles
könnte es werden dieses gerücht gab es
ja lauterbach ich werde das nicht
kommentieren
also ich weiss nur so viel der ist der
er könnte es werden die hessen ich würd
ich will es einfach schlicht nicht
kommentieren aber ich bin zuversichtlich
dass der spd das amt also sehr kompetent
besetzen kann selbst herr merz wünscht
sich jetzt die schon als
gesundheitsminister söder
das ist das nicht dass ihr das
schmeichelt mir aber vielleicht ist das
nicht
und die haben ja sehr diplomatisch
ausgedrückt sie am ende der sendung noch
mal wir kommen zurück zu den impfstoffen
wie können wir dafür sorgen dass nicht
überzeugt sachsen und das sind eben
immer noch leider 40 prozent mit
erstimpfung die fehlen dass die sich
impfen lassen 40 prozent eines
bundeslandes also in der fabrik
forschung oder in der epidemiologie
unterscheidet man immer zwischen einem
überzeugungs problem und einem
management problem ab einem bestimmten
moment ist es nicht mehr das ist nicht
gemanagte einem gewitter nein das geht
nicht es keine kritik an ihm sondern
einfach wie man will wieder vorgang ist
ab einem bestimmten punkt muss man muss
man sagen man auch noch weiter versuchen
zu überzeugen aber der schwerpunkt muss
ich dann verlegen auf das management wie
managen dass ich diese leute zur impfung
bekommen und ich glaube an dem punkt
sind wir jetzt dass wir beispielsweise
durch ein sehr striktes zweig also
regiment durch sehr strikte zweig
kontrollen dass wir also durch die also
einschränkungen also der möglichkeiten
die ungeimpften noch haben im prinzip
ungeimpfte mehr dazu bewegen also dass
wir das in diese richtung managen dass
ungeimpfte den ungeimpften status
aufgeben wollen das muss die überzeugung
zumindest ergänzend aber ich glaube
damit alleiniger überzeugung erreichen
wir hier gar nichts mehr sondern das
management steht im vordergrund wie
sehen sie das herr kennt man reden sie
noch oder müssen sie jetzt eigentlich
schon festlegen und eben auch aus wie
sagt man einsperren geht nicht
aussperren also menschen eben nicht mehr
wir waren das erste bundesland das 2g
eingeführt hat damals auch noch mit sehr
viel kritik und ich höre mich an die
sätze fallen dinge als aus der fdp und
deswegen bin ich auch mal so fassungslos
dass ich jetzt solche sachen werden muss
als wir gesagt haben die pandemische
lage ist nicht zu ende wir brauchen
diese instrumente diese vorhaltungen die
wir bekommen haben als die 2g eingeführt
haben diese ganzen vorhaltungen okay ist
es geschenkt sie haben absolut recht wer
jetzt zum impfen kommt der darf nicht
weggeschickt werden dafür drei stunden
anstehen und es ist in den vergangenen
wochen überall in deutschland
unglaublich viel passiert und ich finde
wir müssen den leuten die der sich
engagiert haben auch danken das sind vor
allen dingen auch die hausärztinnen und
hausärzte was ist in diesen praxen alles
jetzt umgestellt worden wie sehr stellen
diese frauen und männer sich in den
dienst der sache die zahlen gehen massiv
nach oben und das ist eine großartige
entwicklung und dann will ich noch mal
sagen wer über monate oder jahre nur
noch lügen hört der weiß nicht mehr was
die wahrheit ist und glauben sie mir
nehmen sie dieses phänomen mit den
sozialen netzwerken und die hier geht es
vor allen dingen mit dem netzwerk
durchsetzungs gibt es viele gute dinge
gebracht aber hier passiert etwas in
einem bereich was nicht reguliert ist
und das kann uns nicht egal sein diese
leute sind der festen überzeugung dass
sie geschickt werden dass es gar nichts
corona gibt und diese ganzen
verschwörung szenen die wir kennen die
sind davon fest überzeugt und wer vor
davon überzeugt ist wer wo zu neigen
diese leute was macht das mit denen und
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir die
sache klären auf der anderen seite mit
2g mit 3g am arbeitsplatz eine sehr gute
maßnahme wobei man da auch sagen muss
wir kommen an die grenzen dessen was
machbar ist was die tester kapazitäten
an kontrolliert